[Music]
for us at Manchester United Recovery's
his power amount and such a key variable
in the whole performance process for us
of the team immediately after the match
in that first 30-minute period we're
trying to make sure those players are
consuming quick-release carbohydrates
but also protein as well we get the
science and sport rego products directly
in the players hands as soon as they
come off the pitch they've utilized a
lot of carbs muscle glycogen and
depleted and yeah we need to restore
that and if we've got a short turnaround
we need to restore that quick football
it's so dynamic there's a lot of load
going through the muscles so that needs
to be repaired and that's why we put the
proteins in there we do the rego product
it takes three different boxes for as
you have the carbs lipids and proteins
is digital in there so they can take in
one night in year recovery for me is the
priority focus especially at money
United because typically involved in all
competitions and we could have a game
again in 48 hours so it's not just about
being ready first game it's been ready
for the next training session with the
amateur game I think they maybe don't
have the facilities to do everything
that professional may do but definitely
by improving their nutritional intake
immediately post performance or post
training is a hundred percent an easy
win
- better recover and then in turn
enhance performance the recovery is key
for all players and our major focus is
one nutrition and and to sleep there's
no shortcuts there's no quick fixes
training on its own without the correct
nutrition will not where they always get
in the balance right between the two
you
[Music]